welcome back to the realest podcast in
dunya
it's your boys on a friday morning
am i so fired
rami how are you guys doing
so you guys already see the title you
know what time it is
forgiveness
healing that type of stuff
so before we go in
um
what's your relationship with that with
with forgiveness because
me coming into islam and deeper into
islam it's easier to understand these
things and to forgive and to have a more
pure and sound heart but what about you
guys
100 forgiveness is always
i would say the best route to go
but
there is some room for i'd say leniency
with that because you can forgive
someone in terms of the deen
but have this feeling towards him in
terms of the dunya for example
the person who killed the uncle of the
prophet hamza or
the prophet peace be upon him when he
confronted that person later he said
that he forgives them
but that he can't look at them anymore
and to basically leave because like they
can basically bear to to look at them
but the prophet saws he forgave them for
it and i think that
that's really beautiful because it shows
that you know he was a human and just
like us
uh we may not always be able to fully
forgive forget move on and go back to
normal but islam doesn't require that
from you islam doesn't even really
necessarily require forgiveness it just
says that forgiveness is better or
forgiveness is is basically the best
option so that's the stance i take with
inshallah how about you
yeah i think it's the best option
because
isn't it said
by the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was like
how can you expect
to be forgiven if you can't forgive
yourself
yeah i i think the
it just correct me if i'm if i'm wrong
the hadith i think you're talking about
is is one the prophet
he basically kissed one of his his
grandchildren on the forehead or
something and a man came to him and
asked
um you know why do you kiss your
children i have like this many children
grandchildren i never give them any kind
of affection and the prophet islam he
said if you don't show mercy then you
will not receive mercy is that what
you're talking about
there is a generic
belief in islam or just a generic line
that
you know how do you expect allah to
forgive you if you can't even forgive
your brother
yeah yeah
yeah yes could have come from that
hadith bro i'm not sure i haven't heard
that one which is exactly that
yeah
it's difficult
it's difficult to forgive like romney
said we're human and like
you it's the best thing to do though
what if you think about unconditional
love
like unconditional love is gonna forgive
someone like let's say this person
ends
someone's career in your family
you know what i'm referring to here but
you know for pg-13 reasons we'll keep it
like that
so let's say they do that and like a
party is just so angry
and it's like yeah you can forgive them
but yo every time that you see them
it's going to keep bringing that back up
[Music]
i know bro i agree with what you're
saying because
it's it's difficult especially when
someone harms you to that extent that
you were talking about
um
what do you feel like are the side
effects bro from your experience if you
have any that if you don't forgive
someone and you hold it within you
just in the day-to-day life just moving
forward what do you feel what are what
are the things that you're holding on to
well i mean you you constantly have
resentment towards them but then on top
of that like
you just closed yourself off
and now you're you're continuously
keeping yourself closed off
just think about it like if you don't
forgive someone for something then like
a part of you is going to be less
open
to
trusting someone else or accepting
something or just
being as open as you once were before
you know like let's say you smile a lot
and then
someone just got really angry because
you were smiling
nothing to do with you but everything to
do with them and what they were going
through in their day
and then for you it's like yo
why this person do this like i thought
we were cool over here
acting like that with me like is there
something wrong with me like should i
not be smiling so now that person
smiling all the time they're gonna start
smiling less
and it'll get to the point where
they're probably not even smiling at all
i mean just think about this is what
happens like as little kids little kids
are always smiling enjoying themselves
and like after they get hurt multiple
times that's when they start closing off
and it's like a part of them still holds
that resentment
and because they hold their wisdom and
they're closed off and they're not fully
in their in this innocent state that
they were when they were kids
i feel what you mean bro it's like when
you go around and you see those people
that look like they're walking around
with that hurt you know with that chip
on their shoulder
so nightmare to zachary for uh becoming
a member welcome to the family
yeah bro aside from that um rami do you
have any experience with that because i
agree with on 100 like you go around
feeling like you know like you can't
open that part of you that you open to
that person that wronged you and
betrayed you
and now you feel like what if what if i
open myself to that again is the words
going through all that hurt
yeah 100 this is a multi-layered issue
it's it's not just about forgiveness or
not and forgiving and or not forgiving
uh that is basically a big part of it
but it's basically that
lack of forgiveness in that resentment
it becomes what we would call a grudge
and now that grudge is what's really
damaging you having
holding a grudge is kind of like holding
on to a hot coal right because it's it's
fiery it's hot it burns but the longer
you hold on to it the more it affects
you because if you think about if you
let's say someone harms me and i hold a
grudge against them me holding that
grudge against them does not do anything
it does nothing to them for them against
them
it's just me holding a grudge and the
only person you end up hurting
uh is yourself in the end and now
obviously the main hurt was done by them
and that's their fault and um and that's
where the forgiveness comes in
i would i
truly believe that forgiveness is is
only usually for yourself and i'm not
talking about on the day of judgement or
anything i'm talking about when a human
in this life forgives another human i
truly believe that it's only really for
themselves because let's say you know on
hill harms me and i say i forgive you on
hell unless he extremely cares for my
forgiveness it's not going to make a
difference to him he will go about his
life whether i hate him or i love him
so me saying those words i forgive you
is me saying i'm not going to hold a
grudge i'm not going to let it affect me
i'm not going to let it harm me anymore
i'm not going to let it develop into
this trauma that affects me for the rest
of my life i'm going to hold on to the
rope of allah i'm going to hold on to
the the son of the prophet peace be upon
him i'm going to forgive you and i'm
going to keep going about my life and i
know that on the day of judgement uh you
know insha'allah any hardship i went
through allah will reward me for because
i do it for his sake and any wrong that
has you know been committed in this life
allah will make it right on the day of
judgment
yeah bro it is more for you because if
you if you don't forgive him he doesn't
care you're right he's going to go about
his life maybe he might let it go from
him you know his side but maybe he might
not i mean the only person that affects
is you because you're going to go around
always thinking about that always you
know when someone mentions his name
you're going to be bitter and salty
you're not going to say anything you
know it's only affecting you
in in a way it's it's putting you and
keeping you in your head instead of in
the present moment
yeah exactly reminds me it reminds me of
this uh saying
was like
being angry and holding a grudge is like
taking a poison
you know drinking poison and expecting
the other person to be hurt by it
and i definitely like changing
when you're angry or you hold a grudge
it's as if
you're drinking a poison but expecting
it to do harm to the other person when
in reality it's just doing harm to you
yeah that's very true that's very true
subhan allah yeah
okay all this being said and done let's
say someone does harm you what do you
guys how do you guys
dichotomize the whole okay this was
actually something like wrong that they
did to me and this is me overreacting
like this was genuine betrayal
and not you know something in my head as
an insecurity or me being you know petty
or egotistic
versus this is okay they actually did
something that's that's not cool that i
gotta check
yeah so
firstly you have to understand that your
feelings are valid what you're feeling
is okay it's valid but the feelings
being valid doesn't mean that what you
feel um
ought to be how things are morally so
for example let's say that i don't like
someone you know that did something to
me or didn't do something for me
right i might not like that but that
doesn't mean that that person's wrong
sinful haram so when weighing in the
scale whether they're right or wrong if
it's okay or not
you should look at the lens through
islam right
and i would say
to be a little more technical through
their islam do they
do
do their beliefs show that it's a sin
does their mother show that it's a sin
you know is this a issue is this
something that's clear or cut like you
know they come up to me and punch me for
no reason every math would say that
that's you know haram
okay i would look at it from that
perspective first that and my what i'm
feeling is okay but islamically was it
wrong was it haram and then when i
determined that it was an injustice and
feel free to go to a scholar about it
and tell them the full story as well
once you determine that it was actually
an injustice um you can you have two
options basically one you can go to the
person and like try and make it even i'm
not encouraging to go and hit anyone
back i'm not but you know you have the
right to make it even eye for an eye
tooth for a tooth and so on and so forth
the life for our life even
so you have the right islamically
but the but the quran i believe allah is
in the quran but forgiveness is better
forgiveness is best so you could also
take a step back say i'm not going to do
anything instead i'm going to cash this
in on the day of judgment allah is going
to reward me for not going and attacking
or not going and trying to get even
allah will reward me because i have the
right to but i'm holding back and i
think that's the best option as allah
says for two reasons one
what what the heck is the point of
getting even in this life it doesn't do
anything for you except maybe impede
your emotions for a small period of time
and then you become accustomed to doing
that and you just keep doing it every
time you're wrong it's not a great
feeling or you leave it and allah will
give you more on the day of judgment and
increase you on the day of judgement
which is better
obviously
that's the thing bro you remember the
stanford marshmallow test that they did
with kids they give them an option like
you can you can either have this one
marshmallow now or if you wait till i
come back i'll give you two marshmallows
or if i if i tell all of your brothers
and sisters that if i give you you know
100 000 today or if you can wait a week
i'll give you a million
anyone that has you know
the the the wisdom the maturity the
abundance you know they're gonna say
okay no i'll wait delayed gratification
is the way to go you know so there's no
wrong answer here because just like rami
said you are allowed to get even but
isn't it better for you as allah says to
let go
yeah 100
on him bro what are your thoughts
on the question or
yeah let's do the question real quick
another patreon what am i saying what's
remember
so a name we're asked and and you know
welcome to the to the family once again
do i have to disclose my past to a
potential spouse if i've truly changed
left my sins behind and may tawba
[Music]
i don't think
that you have to disclose your past i
mean
ultimately
this is just me this is my opinion
so take it with a grain of salt
um
but you
before what was it called ramen the
thing that you do before is sahara
it's the shadow
yeah you do it's a shot well first you
reflect
on the whole situation that you you are
with this
potential spouse
then you get it's the shadow then i see
it from
someone that you trust
then you do it's the harder
to have clear guidance from allah to see
okay is this really something i'm going
to go through or not is this person
really
meant for me and are they going to be
good for me in this life and in the next
and from there you have clear guidance
because if you have clear guidance from
allah okay this person is the one
well i mean like
you don't really need
to say anything and like even if they
wanted to know i mean i guess you could
but that's already in the past like it
doesn't it doesn't matter
you know it matters to you
in a way allah already concealed the
sins they put a blanket over it like you
said exactly so why like what is the
point you know well i wanna hear what
i'm gonna have to say to it um you know
yeah
for the two dollar two pound super chat
i know it's natural rami is wisdom fight
is enthusiasm and as zee shout out to
you for becoming a member welcome to the
family
what are your thoughts
may allah bless you all
i mean
so
islamically speaking if allah conceals
your sin it's not for you to reveal it
and that's maybe just as big as a sin as
the original sin the fact that allah
made it private concealed it and you go
out and talk about it and usually this
is
said in the in the sense that the person
is boasting about it like oh yeah you
know we went out we got drunk last night
it was so much fun
right
so
uh but it still applies here in the
sense that allah concealed it and you
should not go and reveal it especially
if it is in the past the only and i'm
not a scholar so take what i say with a
grain of salt because what i just said
was the islamic advice as far as i know
maybe islip
i'm just adding a little bit and from
myself and another scholar but what i
want to say is if it would affect the
sister's future
then you should tell her
so if it's something like
you know i
i don't use any graphic examples but you
know there's i would say really a really
bad story of me out there something i
actually did
and if you end up marrying me they might
tie that story to you
um let's say that if the sister is like
you know known in a certain area they
might tie that to you and it might
affect you in your life
that actually might be very detrimental
she might end up you know resenting you
in the future for it why didn't you tell
me all that and it could come out and
really haunt you guys in your marriage
in the future
but if it's something in the sense that
you did it in the past
people don't know about it's not a big
deal you repented and it's not a big
deal in terms of the public eye you
repented he asked a lot to forgive you
then it's not for you to go and reveal
it okay that's that's like you're saying
like if you truly change you know what i
mean like like let's say you know if
somebody has experience with uh previous
partners in jahlia stuff like that if
it's something like let's say they had a
substance addiction and they haven't
fully gotten over that meaning it still
affects their personality it's still
something that will will kind of blow up
on people around them and affect them so
in that case it kind of makes sense to
give them kind of like a warning it's
not really airing your sins in public
but your intention is so that
everything's streamlined with this new
spouse
yeah yeah and that in that case that
would be more of like a character
deficit now that would be more like
um you know this happened to me when i
was younger and i've become very uh
bitter in some cases i'm harder for me
to hold my tongue harder for me to hold
in my anger that you know that that
should be
told because that's not necessarily a
sin it's not saying that you know i did
this to that it's more
so just saying if you are not able to to
handle that in life then you know we
shouldn't do this because what's the
point of
this is the side note but what's the
point of engagement
the engagement period in islam which is
not called that but getting to know
someone
in their family to see if they are
suitable for you and to see if you are
suitable for them it's not
like those stupid reality shows where
everyone gets together and you try and
impress everyone by putting on a facade
in a show and 10 pounds of makeup and
and this huge you know mucho macho
personality and you know i don't care
about any women and then all of a sudden
all the women are running at you because
you you know you you act like you don't
care about them and this stupid game
that's that's not what it is it's this
is my personality this is their
personality this is my belief this is
their belief they're compatible they're
incompatible literally that's all it is
if you're putting on a show and and
lying about who you are then
it's uh it's honestly just setting your
marriage up for failure
okay let me ask y'all a quick uh
some quickness here is this a little
more clean
or if you guys see this
like this
like this looks nicer but it's too big
this looks nicer
yeah this looks nicer too small
and this one with this much text is a
little too big
okay let me do this then while we answer
questions i'll just uh put it to this
okay brother with some ass
the messenger saw some said it is not
lawful for a muslim to forsake his
muslim brother beyond three days and
whosoever does so for more than three
days and dies will certainly enter the
hell
and forsake in in which sense forsake as
in
like you won't speak to them for three
days
call them grudge
yeah
[Music]
yeah i remember when i i
i was discussing this with animal too
that uh you know that's that's the
difference between islam and you know
you know i've heard of people
i'm not gonna lie i've heard of people
in islam in muslim families you know
hold grudges but you know it's it's not
something that is islamically backed up
if anything just like the brother here
said something we shouldn't do
yeah
yeah 100 especially when it comes to
family family is a whole different story
because when it comes to family
the prophet saw he specifically told us
not to break the ties of kinship so you
would
technically be obligated to you know
visit your parents your siblings a
certain amount of times maybe to even
bring gifts and try and you know
reconcile and all of that and just show
that you don't you know hate them or
anything crazy like that
okay
uh before we go on to the next topic i
have a quick uh physics question for uh
angel bro we got 75 viewers in the
stream bro how many likes should we have
on this video
in all seriousness bro
you really want to know the answer yeah
like you got to do the equation probably
so now we got 79 viewers bro how many
likes should we have on the stream
minimum 183 minimum 183 you guys heard
it here first i don't know how you got
it i still don't know i'm not as good as
math as in but 183 likes minimum on this
live stream what are you guys doing okay
next topic next topic is gonna be regret
so we get a lot of dms from a lot of
brothers and sisters saying okay
i've done this in the past i've made
tawba to allah you know i've repented
for my sins but how do i know allah has
even forgiven me i regret i i wish i had
never done this in the first place you
know you hear me say a lot you know
but
like is it really that easy to like just
let go of your pastor on me like what
are some strategies that people should
adopt
so i think the first mistake is putting
it all kind of
on themselves so if a person makes a sin
or commits a sin and then they ask a lot
to span out
to forgive them sincerely as long as
they are sincere allah forgive them so
what you're really
doubting in that point is allah's
forgiveness if you don't have sincerity
then just renew your intentions make
tawba again be as sincere as possible
and that's something you were supposed
to keep purifying it's called task
test
purification of the sulfur purification
of the heart something we all have to do
every single day as muslims and may
allah make us people who purify
ourselves allah i mean allah says in the
quran he who purifies the nephs uh has
succeeded and he who fails to has
basically failed so
as muslims we be as sincere as we can we
try and be as sincere as possible we ask
allah to forgive us for any
transgression we committed
but at the end of the day if we're
doubting allah forgave us why are you
doubting it because you're not sincere
because allah is not al-rafir
not he's not the most forgiving and the
most merciful and that would actually
fall into kuffar if you actually were to
believe that so as long as you know that
it's not on you it's on allah and allah
is capable of all things allah is fully
capable and willing to forgive you and
to grant you mercy
as long as you are sincere and that sign
of being worried about your sincerity is
a sign that you're sincere imagine you
make toba like oh allah forgive me and
you just went on with your day like you
didn't care
that's a sign that you're not sincere
so the more worried you are about it
then i would say the more sincere you
seem to be
it reminds me of uh
i'm pretty sure it was in a podcast but
you and me talked about this around me
where it's like
if you question
your faith
you know if you
you're kind of having doubts
about your beliefs and you know islam
and all this stuff it's like
i think that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said that that's a sign
of high iman
because it shows that you actually
believe
that you have the doubts you you believe
if you didn't believe and the doubts
came in like there wouldn't really be
doubts you would just not believe it
yeah we went on
another in our patreon video bro and for
those of you all that know no patreon
exclusive content man we post content
that never airs on youtube on patreon so
patreon if you think we're real on
youtube for one rami
what are they going to get on patreon
bro on patreon they're going to get a
whole new level of realness because
there are things we can't say on patreon
although sorry on youtube although it's
the truth so go to patreon and get the
exclusive content and the exclusive
truth that youtube won't allow there we
go there we go you get that soundcloud
link to the cuisine
that's the highest tier that's the
highest yield though yeah yeah there's
multiple tiers though too so lowest tier
start at five dollars a month you know
five dollars a month you just become you
know you get all the exclusive banned
content that we can't post on youtube or
that we posted on youtube and it got
removed but then they have higher tiers
where they can speak to us one-on-one
and just you know be homies with us so
yeah just to bring it back to that point
the point that was mentioned on patreon
um
imagine just like cement wall and hill
just said imagine you woke up and you
had this thought that maybe unicorns
don't exist
right you're not going to be like oh my
god my life is ruined oh unicorns i'm
like let me go study let me go ask a
chef do unicorns
you never believe them to begin with it
doesn't make a difference to you if
whether they're real or not because you
never believe them to begin with now if
your entire belief was centered around
unicorns and yeah you're in a bit of a
pickle you've been in a bit of a problem
same thing with islam same thing with
your iman and allah and islam if you get
doubts about your religion which people
have messaged me dummy was literally
like i'm so like i couldn't sleep at
night because i was thinking about you
know what david wood said where he
took something out of context
misinterpreted mistranslated it threw it
in a blender and then put it on youtube
and it's like
okay this is good for two reasons one it
shows you truly believe in islam because
if you did it it wouldn't bother you and
two
when you get the answer to it it'll
literally increase you in iman because
what is iman
on hill what is the iman bro
acceptance of a fact boy yeah exactly
amen
is the acceptance of a fact
using basically evidence to prove that
it's it's correct it's in life reality
yeah how's that difference in blind
faith
blind faith is literally like you close
your eyes and basically say i believe in
jesus or died for my sins i believe in
11 000 gods i believe in it's not based
on reality it's not based on evidence
it's based on
basically following people blindly what
they say like if i came to you and i
said you know drink this uh purple
liquid it'll make you
superman
and you're like oh my god that's amazing
and you drink it
then
okay you're following based on blind
faith but if you
see a peer-reviewed study about like you
know black seed
and you're like oh based on this
evidence black seed has this benefit
that would be you have a man that black
seed black seeds are actually good for
you so similarly to in islam
since its acceptance of a fact once you
learn more about islam you're accepting
more facts about islam you literally
have more iman
okay as he says
us in switzerland bro we were all just
talking about one day you know inshallah
hitting up switzerland for a trip and
knowing that we have some subscribers
there some family there like yourself
that wants to you know
see us when we do come if we do come in
sha allah it'd be an honor
so jazakallah for that and shout out to
project for becoming a member
here for the example
have you really brought it home
it was a good partnership i'm glad he
mentioned
all right last thing that is on the list
today let's say let's say you
you have
repented you have done the work to you
know
let go and trust that allah has forgiven
you like what i'm saying and not judging
and limiting one of allah's qualities
and attributes of infinite mercy and
maximum mercy uh stuck for allah let's
say you do all this
yet you still have this this random
subconscious insecurity that you just
can't let go
so let's say someone lied to you in the
past now you can't ever
say something to someone else share
something with someone else let's say
let's say someone's betrayed you now you
can't you know open yourself up to
anyone else it's not even in your
control like you tried but you can't
let's say someone does you wrong and now
you can never trust another girl what do
you do in this scenario
is it time is it is there something like
is there still a character deficiency
that you got to work towards is there
something you know in ibadah that you
got to do
on her you want to take this one or
maybe fight you should answer your own
question
yeah why don't you answer your own
question though
okay cool this question that we commonly
get the way i usually answer it is time
all right this is just for me
usually usually most of the things in
life just take time
a good example of this is let's say
grief
um
you get really attached to someone let's
say something happens to them god forbid
and let's say you know the time here is
uh is prematurely coming to an end uh or
has come to an end and you now feel like
okay because of this i can no longer
attach myself to someone else i can no
longer let myself form a relationship or
a bond or a connection with someone else
because what if this happens to them
again right this feeling of loss of
grief really does go like a way over
time it might take a short amount of
time it might take a few weeks it might
take a few months it might take a few
years it might even take decades
what i know is this even if you never
really get over it or it never leaves
you the feeling it gets easier to manage
and deal with over time as time
progresses you begin to like have
normalcy slowly but surely creep back
into your life it's not gonna be
something like that's forever there
and even if it is it gets more
manageable it might seem like that in
the in the short term when you're going
you know through it it's like man i
can't even eat i can't even sleep i
can't even do this than the other but
over time it does get easier
yeah 100 100
that's that's one example of like you
know getting hurt from someone and
grieving like for example you love
someone and they end up passing away but
what about the case where what you
mentioned before you love a woman and
she ends up breaking your heart or you
love a man he end up breaking your heart
or you do business with someone and they
rip you off
how do you deal with
that
it's still a question bro tough question
i'm gonna stop another
bro i don't think i understand the
question because i spaced out when you
were actually saying the question the
first time that's why i was like bro i
think you should answer your question
first
that's funny bro that's funny so uh rami
do you want to repeat it or do you want
me to reiterate
it's your question inshallah go for it
okay bro so basically
if somebody does you wrong to the point
where it was not your fault it was their
fault
because of this you subconsciously have
this insecurity now what if this happens
again
whether someone cheats on you whether
someone lies to you whether someone
steals from you whether someone betrays
your trust and honor and integrity or
violates you
how do you now go on to life knowing
this might happen again
when you
in your best of your capability you've
done everything to become a better man
you've done the work you've done the
tawba you've done the you know the
healing let's see you've tried to purify
your heart but for some reason it's
still inside you like i can't open up
myself and put myself in that scenario
again and now you have this wall you
just can't be vulnerable
um
well
number one you have to ask a lot
to open you up
because i mean when we're closed off
like that like
it's very difficult you know and it's
not no it's not going to happen unless a
lot was it so that's number one
um number two you said they already did
the uh healing
but healing is also a thing that like
occurs over time so it might take their
entire life to be able to heal from that
and i'd say the last thing
is just understanding
that whether you're open
or closed
you're gonna get hurt either way
so
[Music]
why not just be open
okay yeah yeah i agree as he writes
allah azzawajal makes everything easy
and you should always have trust
tawakkal in him and in his qatar his
divine decree so even if someone hurts
you you should have subber patience
and know that it had her goodness in it
inshallah yeah yeah insha allah 100
uh one thing i want to add to this
discussion inshaallah is
let's say you i'm going to link three
scenarios together because i think they
all are basically the same thing just
kind of represented differently so like
you know a love interest when hurt when
they hurt you or a friend when they
betray you or
doing business with someone that end up
ripping you off
you are
i almost i almost want to say obligated
and i'm not using this as like a
shuttery like islamic like
ruling term i'm just saying as a human
you owe it to yourself right
again because i'm not a sheikh you owe
it to yourself to do what islam tells
you to do which is now this is a shuttle
like def not definition but shuttery
fact that when someone
uh slanders a person
or
uh shows that they're untrustworthy in
their testimony in terms of them for
example even narrating a hadith in the
time of like the the salaf
the you know uh the first two
generations if they narrowed a hadith
that was proven to be false and this
kept happening their testimony is just
not taken anymore at all
and they're not trusted as a person so
if someone hurts you when they show that
you can't trust them you owe it to
yourself to stay away from that person
in the sense that you don't trust them
anymore because you can be on good terms
with someone and forgive someone and not
share all your little secrets with them
not allow yourself to open up and like
fall deeply in love with them
because you've been talking like every
night for the past 10 months which would
be haram to begin with um
and same thing like with a friend and
something with the guy who ripped you
off in business you don't have to go do
business with them again you'd be like
no you ripped me off you know get the
heck out of my face
but you can forgive them you don't have
to hold it against them so those
it's basically kind of like a
a false dichotomy that that you that
people make that either i forgive them
and do business again or i hate them
forever and it's not it's not the only
two options that's one and secondly what
i wanted to say about uh you know being
hurt by people is you can ascribe it to
them and then take what you learn from
it and apply in life because it's not
bad that you're worried about getting
you know that happening again that's you
your necks yourself learning to protect
yourself it's called wisdom it's called
learning and growing and adapting so now
when you see the same signs in a
business partner that you saw in the
first one
your alarm will be up and then you'll
take extra precautions to know you're
not going to get ripped off maybe you'll
have witnesses for the contract and
you'll make sure that he signs his name
and he he puts whatever to prove that
he's the one signing it
maybe if you're a sister you'll ask a
little bit more um from the brother who
you're looking to marry for the maher
because you know he makes enough money
to afford it you're not asking for his
whole bank account but maybe you're
asking what he makes in you know a few
months
and that would be a lot to him perhaps
[Music]
uh you know you never really know
someone until you you either live with
him yeah do business with him or travel
yeah yeah 100
and i think that's the biggest injustice
you know thinking we know people and all
that but this is why we get hurt we're
naive we get hurt we learn from it what
you can't do
because it would be an injustice to
yourself is put that on all men put it
on all women put on all of society put
on all business owners that everyone's
like that that generalization is not
harming them
well it might be if it's a societal
level everyone hates them but that
generalization is harming you because as
a man you close yourself off to women
you close yourself off to marriage
you close yourself off to the idea of
starting a family same thing with a
woman you close yourself off to the idea
of getting married having a husband
being taken care of having children and
so on and so forth and there will come a
time where you regret that and that
damage is going to be a lot more severe
than the damage you initially felt of
getting your heart broken and all of
that it's going to be longer lasting
it's going to be more permanent so
that's why you don't throw it on to
everyone
all right all right all right
it's now open to the public
usher writes 8j jj i'm not sure what
that means maybe they met the right high
hit jason there
a bit of a loaded question to be honest
because what you're the question almost
begs us to generalize all she has which
is it's problematic because you have the
shia as that have beliefs that take them
out of islam and you have she has to
have beliefs that keep them in the fall
of islam so shiraz as a whole i would
say generally okay they're muslim until
they they're proven to not be if a
person has a belief that takes them out
of the full of islam then that person is
not muslim but you can't do take around
all of the shias like we do take it on
all of the ahmadis
very very good answer bro
i remember uh you know i know being near
weaver and all for anyone watching that
for one if anyone's watching it didn't
like the video what are you doing man
come on like the video but two if you're
watching and you didn't know that an
house a river mashaallah and he's made
such tremendous progress in uh in the
past few months
there was one thing that angel would
repeatedly ask us and he's like if if
islam truly is like one message one
prophet
one god and it's like this just simple
one truth then why are there multiple
sects why is there division in the ummah
so rami do you want to answer that again
because you know a lot of people might
not know the answer to that
yeah so first and foremost uh
dividing into sects and not being united
as an ummah is something the prophet
peace be upon him knew and something
allah told him would happen so there's a
there's a hadith with a prophet salaam
he makes dua to allah
to not let another nation overtake our
nation not not let us be destroyed by
another nation allah accepted that
and then the prophet saw that
you know allah don't allow my nation to
be destroyed by any natural disaster and
allah accepted that dua and then he made
the dua oh allah don't allow my my ummah
to be divided and to start you know
fighting with each other and
basically part into sects and allah said
that this is their test
so although allah and the process
commanded us to stay united to not
divide into sects and all that
allah spent allah told the prophet and
he knew and he showed us that he knew
that we would eventually so it doesn't
discredit islam that people divide it
into sects because
we that would actually
in a way kind of
it may discredit the idea of free will
because
unless every single individual in the
muslim ummah
or every group within the ummah decide
to follow one exact way of thinking
you're going to have differences of
opinion and some differences of opinion
will develop into being other sects you
will have people like isis that claim to
be muslim
but they're definitely another sect you
will have people like ahmadi who claim
to be muslim but they're not even
accepted in islam they're kuffar and
this is all because people have free
will they can choose to do that they can
choose to fight with other muslims they
can choose to have these you know these
little disagreements that they turn into
a big deal if you look at some of like
the metrali salafis and how they treat
the ashari the mathuridis and the other
muslims who have different al-qaeda than
them even though they're still within
the perimeter of islam they treat them
like they're not muslims that kind of
sectarianism is not what the umma needs
although it's something we have it's
something we're tested with and we need
to deal with as an ummah
i mean bro i mean
man
i hope that answers
questions in regards to one of the uh
the subscribers they said that we need
to make a discord
we're going to make a discord inshallah
it's wonderful
it's on the way i've been messing around
with the whole nft things and
been playing around with the the discord
communities over there so
we shot a lot of
you know the brother that helped us uh
that's helping us with the website
so another subscriber dm uh dm me and
said that you know i know the other
brother personally and i'm a specialized
you know discord uh i create discord
servers and i've been doing it for five
years
and uh you know he'd love to help us out
so inshallah that's another sign of
getting the the comments now so that's
another sign uh we'll do it inshallah
project right salon brothers glad to
join this chat thank you for joining and
uh becoming a youtube member just wanted
to say i enjoy the channel may allah
reward you for all your hard work keep
you on the straight path keep preaching
i mean may accept it
i mean
they love us for the sake of allah we
love you as well for the sake of allah
all right how does one go about gaining
the self-conviction that they are
following the right sect so firstly i
would say remove the idea of sex i
wouldn't i wouldn't consider
um salafis a sect i wouldn't consider
sufis a sect i wouldn't consider any of
these sects and the fact that we do
consider them sects is problematic
because that in and of itself is
dividing into sects because as long as a
person is within the fold of islam
they are a muslim
because in islam you have things that
are qatari that are clear-cut that you
cannot disagree with or that you cannot
believe in and there are things that are
done there there's differences of
opinion and that difference of opinion
allows for there to be people who
believe in different things so khalas
that's it's okay that people believe in
different things but
in terms of what you believe how do you
know what you believe is actually true
and good well it has to be based in
evidence so you have to look at the
evidence you have to you know study
arabic you have to study the works of
the scholars and you have to see what
you believe and if it's actually based
in the quran and actually based on the
sunnah now when you're doing this keep
in mind that there are things that are
katahi and things that are done there
are things that have 100 evidence that
you need to believe in for example the
prophet being the last uh prophet allah
says that in the quran so it's clear
it's qatari but there are other things
like did the prophet isaiah go in the
night journey to heaven full body and
soul or did he go with just his soul if
you choose either opinion it's okay
because neither of them are 100
proved
islamically with evidence you don't have
a hadith that says he went body and soul
you don't have a hadith that says he
only went with the soul so that
difference of opinion is allowed there
that would not take you out of the
fullness
okay perfect bro next question by the
way guys we're not trying to you know
rush through the questions but rami and
and angel and myself we try to give
quality in our quantity so we can't give
you know and we can't answer all the all
the comments it makes no sense so if you
do want a priority just send a super
chat or become a youtube member
insha'allah
so gonna write song brothers how should
i try and persuade one of my english
white mates that allah is real and islam
is the truth allah but i've been to make
them uh i've been wanting to make them
believe but they just end up being
annoyed in the end
you do little by little
and if if the words is too much
then you leave by example or you give
the dollar by example
with your actions
shout out to uh the saudi riyals from uh
brother mahmoud
all right two times mashallah
okay
oh
i think onwards apparently
well first off
you should
go to your parents talk to them
uh
but then from there it's it's just a
matter of like
self-reflecting
and constantly asking allah to
heal you up from the trauma
because again like
it's gonna happen
when it's time
not when you wanted to but when it's
time
to happen and that might be
today that might be a few weeks from now
a few months from now a few years from
now
but you just got to constantly be
striving to heal because again you're
asking a lot to heal you
but you have to make the actions like
allah says in the quran it's not going
to change
the situation of anyone until they
change what's
within themselves
so you have to constantly keep making an
effort
and that's why i said self-reflection
because
usually on the day-to-day spectrum we
have a ton of thoughts going on inside
our head
that we're not really aware of
and sometimes we'll have a thought that
comes in and we'll be thinking about it
but we might get distracted with
something or it might just be too much
to deal with in the moment so we just
push it aside for the time being that's
where the self-reflection is very
important because you're taking that
time out to really just ask yourself the
questions like okay well why do i feel
this way why did i experience this why
did i run away and not face that head-on
when i was a kid why why do i still
experience this trauma like this you
know you're asking yourself these hard
questions
and you're staying with them so that way
you can come to conclusions and what i
usually tell people is
get yourself a journal
and when you reflect
write down the most important parts that
come to you
that way when you reflect the next time
you have a bookmark
you have a place marker as to where you
left off
because it's like reading a book it's
like reading the quran
you're not going to read the quran the
entire way through
you're going to read a little bit
and then you're going to put a bookmark
so that the next time you come in
you're starting fred you're not starting
fresh but you're starting from where you
left off
marshall
for the other book recommendation too
seems
for numerical miracles of the quran did
you see it
uh no i didn't where it really just sent
it like instagram damn or like email let
us know where you sent this
another one i do a lot of mistakes the
same mistake every time any advice on
how to fight it
well what else is before the others go
on that the greatest problem is not
knowing you have a problem so the fact
that you're you're cognizant this is an
issue you're already ahead of the game
most people
uh romney
you want to go or you want me to go
how do you take it go ahead
uh like i said reflect on it
constantly reflect on it
ask allah to help you get past it and
take action because again allah is not
going to change the situation of anyone
until they change what is within
themselves the way you change what is
within yourself
is by reflecting and taking action
one
100
percent allah bless you uh the wealthy
llama i mean so
i would say that it depends on what the
thing is and how severe it is if it's
like an addiction that's something that
you might need you know more
professional help with but if it's
something like smaller that's just a bad
habit maybe like swearing and all of
that these are things that you can work
on over time and i would say you must
start by detesting it and once you
detest it you know it's something that
cognitively you know that if you do
you're gonna have some kind of
dissonance and that will slowly move you
away from it take example from the
prophet to them take example uh you know
from the quran what allah describes you
know the best of people and how they
were and all of that
and over time you might just grow out of
it just keep trying keep pushing but if
it's a more severe issue and it's rooted
in your nephs and your desires then you
need to take a more stern approach you
need to preoccupy yourself with things
very specifically at very specific times
like let's say you end up doing the sin
at uh you know 7 p.m
on the weekends make sure 7 p.m on the
weekends you're like at the gym there's
no way you can do it or 7 p.m on
weekends you're working or something
like that to get you away from it you
have to really break the problem down
and make a plan and stick to it to grow
out of it inshallah
why was the man's blocked for five
minutes
we got three minutes left before we
gotta wrap this up
so guna writes thank you brothers i will
keep trying also have you got any real
advice for protection against the evil
eye as i think my little brother is
currently suffering from it and is very
ill recently
protect your brother and your family
allah i mean what you want to do is make
sure that your whole family abstains
from any sins right
um having any nudges anything that's you
know impure in the house
and you want to pray your salah do
everything that's father that lost
has commanded that we do and you want to
read surah
in the last three surahs of the quran
three times each
in the mornings at fajr and in the
evenings
do this and continually do it and keep
doing it
until insha'allah it's better it makes
allah protect you allah mashallah and
sort of as well
easy rights off topic wanted to know
what languages do you guys know you guys
want to go first i only speak arabic but
i'm learning rp or i only speak english
but i'm learning artery that's what i
meant to say
i know
english
spanish
portuguese
very very tiny bit of thai
and i'm learning arabic now
and inshallah i'll learn uh
french as well
writes a million dollar advice from rami
everyone take notes that's what i do
first of all you know french
no i said inshallah i'll learn french oh
inshallah okay
i know english spanish portuguese
a little bit of thai
and a little bit of arabic learning
arabic though
um but then french as well
in the future i'll learn that one
inshallah my guys just throwing random
ones in there like bro i could just say
30 languages right now be like yo
inshallah i'll learn
[Laughter]
no no i mean
bro i i know at least three languages
okay that's that's fair that's right
three persona you know for me you know
bengali uh english a little bit of
urdu
hindi punjabi you know a little bit
um easy to understand me what about you
i already answered it i only speak
english and i'm learning how to be like
you don't know french bro
no bro heck no i forgot that the second
i stopped learning in school here we go
there we go our vibes
[Laughter]
okay we got one to two last questions
that we're gonna answer before we end
this one off
let's answer this one i gotta i gotta
head out all right perfect
okay
hi bro enjoy your gym journal
all right so
uh let's not we're gonna we're not gonna
obviously be two we're not even gonna
read this question out to be honest
we're just gonna display it um and we're
not gonna you know obviously go too
in-depth because it's youtube this is
not patreon there's a lot of terms that
we can't say
but how would you
very lightly skim over this aroma and
answer it
it's uh that's really funny to be
completely honest so
firstly if a person uh calls you one of
these terms or associates you with
certain people
because you defend the
hadith then why don't you pull out the
hadith that refutes those people and
what they do
like where the prophet peace be upon him
talks about the
and how they're the dogs of hellfire
then it would basically smack what he's
saying in in his face you just take the
evidence
and you show it show that these people
what they do is political and not
islamic and then show him why him and
his quranus views
are
are actually kaffar
and they fall into disbelief and that he
himself doesn't know what islam is
practically
because the quran who doesn't explain
everything
specifically it mentions everything
generally you'll have one ayah that will
say something general that will
encompass all of these things but
everything that it encompasses we just
don't know because we lack the
information so what we do is we go to
the hadith because even the quran
allah i'll find the ayah if you need
allah says that we sent the quran so
that you may explain it to them
that's what he says so that the prophet
may explain the quran to us
show him that ayah now the prophet has
to explain it to us how does he explain
it to us in the 21st century with the
hadith and show him the signs of hadith
and how we know these were actually the
words of the prophet peace be upon him
because we have chains of narrations and
these people being
criticized to see if they're actually
good narrators and truthful or not
meaning speculative there could be you
know different understandings of it and
so on and so forth and those who look to
spread mischief in surah
chapter 3 verse 7
says that in the book there are clear
verses and others are ambiguous he said
the clear verses are the foundation of
the book and he says that those who look
to spread mischief and doubt rely on the
ambiguous verses and their false
interpretations of them show them all of
that insha allah it will really smack
his belief
my mind muted it right away like mike
dropped all right so it's friday it's
time for juma soon anyone watching that
hasn't gone to drama if you're a male if
you're a brother
it's mandatory right a lot of people
don't know this but it's mandatory we
remind it every week go to jamma do your
best get a ride pick up your lads you
know go make make make it happen it's
it's not that long you know
uh take uh take a bath first uh you know
it's uh recommended uh and then you know
make wudu put something nice on and just
just make it happen
no excuse all right
sisters is not obligatory but there's no
you know definitely
if you do it but brothers mandatory
let's go okay one last question and then
we're done
now that i think about it and someone
can correct me from wrong i actually
think there's more reward for a woman
praying at home
i believe
the prophet saws did say that that
there's more reward for um men if
they're you know closer to the front in
the masjid and for women if they're
they're closer to the back
you know so
i did hear that that one too bro that
you said
um
okay all right that's it
am i right may allah almighty bless you
brothers with utmost goodness in this
life and uh next
okay one last question there we go you
came clutch youtube members
do we read
every friday the prophet sent him he did
instruct us to read um so i believe he
just said 10
so it could be the first 10 to the last
10.
um but maybe you know why not both um i
actually have not memorized the first 10
and the last 10 only some from the first
10 so i read that but it's about time in
sha allah memorize the rest
of 10 years
right yeah first tanayat masha allah
okay there you go you have it first um
and i'm on the same boat as a tsunami
definitely we got to get on there
for the reminder why yeah
that being said
have a
a blessed uh year insha allah in life i
mean i'm
[Music]
foreign
[Music]